d'un tout petit qui fait un maquis de
300 qui sous photothérapie
voici lucas il est né il y a trois jours
la lumière bleue de la photothérapie
c'est pour soigner la jaunisse très
fréquente chez les prématurés
[Musique]
quand la lumière revient les infirmières
recouvre la couveuse
c'est pour protéger de la lumière
ce sont des grands que nature et donc on
essaye au maximum de reproduire l'utérus
de la maman c'est vraiment essayé de le
plus possible de permettre cette
position un petit peu faits tels qu'ils
étaient dans le ventre de maman
c'est pour ça qu'on essaye au maximum de
représenter un petit peu sa part nos
mains et par les venge
[Musique]
il y à la réunion deux fois plus de
prématurée que dans l'hexagone
car la prématurité est lié à des
facteurs comme le diabète l'hypertension
et la précarité en général
en france on estime qu'un enfant est
viable à partir de 24 semaines de
grossesse
cinq mois et demi et s'il pèse minimum
500 grammes
vous
et pour ces tout petits bébés il faut
des toutes petites couches nous avons la
taille d'écran trop mature et les
enfants qui font à peu près le sein à
partir de 500 grammes jusqu'à avait 1 1
qui n'y voient là car je vais vous
montrer par rapport à la taille de ma
main ce que ça donne vraiment ces micro
le service de réanimation en
néonatologie du centre hospitalier de
bellepierre peut accueillir 12 enfants
des prématurés mais également des bébés
présentant de graves pathologies
donc je reviens
on va faire ta petite séance de kiné
respiratoire
elia est une très grande prématurée né à
25 semaines de grossesse elle peser 740
grammes
des plaines en contenu et depuis trois
mois elle n'a pas quitté le service de
réanimation
car les grands prématurés développent
souvent de graves pathologies et des
complications liées au développement un
complet de leurs systèmes vitaux
alors là je lui fais la kiné
respiratoire pour l'aider à remonter si
ces questions parce qu'elle exhale
encombré donc on met des petites
pressions au niveau du thorax et de
l'abdomen
dans la chambre à côté une maman campe
sur un lit pliant depuis trois semaines
son petit garçon a été transféré depuis
mayotte dans le cadre d'une évacuation
sanitaire car il souffrait d'un grave
retard de croissance
cela fait maintenant
tout ça
les sages de nerfs mais malheureusement
pour papier sa rage la source
je vous laisse moi je vais prendre des
compresses
c'est par là moi j'attends passait par
les pieds
pourquoi jugeote comme ça twitte ans
les prématurés ils sont très sensibles
sur tous les points
vous parlez tous moi on a des gestes
très lent on les prévient quand on les
bouge quand on est tous
si vous
e
[Musique]
juste installé sur levante pour la
petite katia c'est l'heure du petit
déjeuner
[Musique]
la quantité est la 3008
c'est le son qui passe par ruse qui va
directement dans l'estomac la 200
piscines
à ce rythme
elle les données aux prématurés et du
lait maternel un médecin explique donc à
la maman de katia l'importance de tirer
son lait
c'est moins d'un kilo simple donc elle a
besoin de lait maternel parce que sinon
le lait artificiel est trop agressif
pour année donc là il faut alors c'est
vrai que c'est contraignant tirer les
ens paris go c'est pas sympa mais aussi
de faire le plus souvent possible
quelques instants plus tard nous
retrouvons le petit benays dans les bras
de sa maman
vous êtes inquiet
où
parce que nous apparaissent plus à plein
temps pour ellen
et toujours pareil solution
epad a menacé
alors vous rester près de lui tout le
temps vous voulez pas partie je suis là
j'aimerais parfois poids par rapport à
vos papiers être hébergés malgré
l'inquiétude de la maman l'assistante
sociale va tenter de la convaincre
d'aller logé à la maison des parents une
structure d'hébergement situé à
proximité de l'hôpital et jessica la
maman délia elle vient d'arriver à
l'hôpital et l'anesthésiste vient
d'informer qu'il va falloir opérer sa
petite fille la petite fille à une grave
affection de la rétine si on ne le perd
pas elle risque de perdre la vue de les
faire des câlins pour achever
tous les jours on propose aux mamans de
pratiquer le peau à peau
la série une technique qui a prouvé
depuis longtemps c'est bien fait pour la
mère et l'enfant
[Musique]
voilà
c'était du bonheur que ça contre nous
de bien sortir
la chaleur
et là vous ne voyez pas comme quand vous
avez encore je les voie rentrer à la
maison
pour l'instant on sait pas encore
peut-être ça va encore durer deux mois
mais demande à dieu que vingt jours si
tout ça ça va s'arranger que et le
prisme à des rentrées à la maison j'ai
tous nos
[Musique]